I read a lot of science fiction when I was young,...
...so people like Clark and Asimov and Heinlein.
Most of the books Heinlein wrote were pretty straightforward,...
...aimed at a pretty young audience.
And so, I read all of those.
Then he wrote a couple where he wasn't aiming them at kids at all.
They were actually representing more of his overall philosophy of life...
...and concerns that he had.
So both "Stranger in a Strange Land" and "Moon Is a Harsh Mistress"...
...were so different than what he'd written before...
...where "Stranger in a Strange Land" is so much more complicated than the other ones.
It has somebody raised on Mars...
...who hasn't been exposed to normal human society...
...and he almost becomes like a religious figure,...
...sort of figuring out a new sense of human purpose and religion.
These books were supposed to help you...
...think about how things worked in the real world.
The word "grok," I think, was first used in that book...
...and that seemed kind of cool...
...and it had some liberal, almost hippie-type moral values.
This is the late 60s, early 70s.
They had kind of this truth telling, justice idea.
So it's kind of subversive.
It's a pretty profound book, especially when you've read all those other books...
...that you could just kind of plow through...
...and you knew who the hero was and the bad guy was.
The endings were always kind of tidy, which in this case,...
..."Stranger in a Strange Land,"...
...the end is not that tidy.
You kind of don't know what to think.
The author is kind of telling you,...
..."Hey, the future of humanity is pretty unclear as well."